I was want to pull over and just pick up
all this [ __ ] litter kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] does that kind of person
that rides a bicycle out on the street
that's what doesn't I already have like
a huge temper and I'm trying to learn
how to control it and driving on these
streets out here like makes me lose my
[ __ ] again you know people always say
with your anger is when you have
expectations to other people but what
can I say I'm a dreamer all right we're
in Hollywood right now nobody knows how
to [ __ ] drive out here motorcycle I
always look out for these guys but I do
not care about people on bicycles in LA
it's not a tragedy if you die out here
this such [ __ ] [ __ ] they ride right
out in the street right they're always
telling you share the road and they
won't get the [ __ ] over get over you see
me behind you I'm in a [ __ ] car get
the [ __ ] over always giving you the
finger and [ __ ] acting like they're
these [ __ ] angels right they never
stop at stop signs they don't obey the
rules of the world that's what the [ __ ]
they're supposed to do and then they
[ __ ] ride right out in the middle of
the road like like you pulled up into
their own bike race with this stupid
[ __ ] tight outfits on like they're
doing some sort of Time Trial that
anybody gives a [ __ ] about anyone they
frost the bicycle to like it was a
[ __ ] tragedy was inevitable you're on
a motorcycle without a [ __ ] engine
driving out in traffic where people are
texting gee what could go wrong
so just [ __ ] sneak over I'll go over
the double line a little bit I'll get
around you you won't get hit nobody has
to frost the [ __ ] bicycle okay look
at this see this this person coming up
in the scooter look what I do look what
I do I get over go ahead
go live your dream go find love who this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
get out of the [ __ ] Road look at this
place
he's pretty dumb right you can't get mad
but you look funny if I hit her it's my
fault
you're on a [ __ ] scooter crossing
four lanes of [ __ ] traffic who raised
her right aren't you supposed to have a
helmet on if you're on a bicycle just
[ __ ] edge over I don't want to hit
you all right but the longer you stay
out there it starts to feel like a good
option I shouldn't have said that that
was irresponsible but then again that's
who I am
[Music]